C'era una volta C'era una volta
un'impresa un'impresa fatta di
imprenditori di grandi uomini nomi che
tutti ci ricordiamo come
Enzo Ferrari Pietro Ferrero o tanti
altri che rimangono nel cuore di cui di
ognuno di noi con i prodotti che hanno
creato e hanno portato nella nostra vita
ma se pensate bene come fa si faceva
comunicare negli anni sessanta quanto
questi uomini hanno comunicato il loro
prodotto Beh non era facile non era
facile la comunicazione costava tanto ci
volevano molti investimenti e
soprattutto non conoscevano Chi era il
proprio pubblico Ma le uniche persone
con cui si confrontavano erano la
propria famiglia la propria società e
perché no i propri operai e quindi
cercavano di capire da quelli che gli
stavano intorno qual era il loro bisogno
che cosa avevano bisogno quali prodotti
creare e soprattutto con che parole e in
che modo comunicarli
E allora cosa faceva l'imprenditore
l'imprenditore era una specie di eroe un
eroe che partiva andava in missione si
vestiva con i propri vestiti i suoi
prodotti i prodotti trasmettevano un
valore e li portava li portava nel mondo
li portavano nel mondo
e devono una specie di
elisir di qualcosa di magico di qualcosa
che seppur nel suo piccolo rappresentava
la felicità per il proprio target i
propri consumatori Ma se noi oggi
guardassimo questa immagine con gli
occhi di oggi con gli occhi di un
consumatore del 2023
non accuseremo Forse questa azienda di
promuovere un prodotto chimico una
schiuma qualcosa che fa male
all'ambiente non ci verrebbe così di
impeto da scrivere sui social No state
vedendo all'immagine delle donne Perché
le donne devono stendere un bucato
è proprio così E quindi cosa è successo
a un certo punto le aziende hanno capito
che il pubblico parlava con loro erano
più solo loro a comunicare con il
pubblico e quindi hanno dovuto cambiare
la propria comunicazione e hanno dovuto
iniziare a parlare di qualcosa che
andasse al di fuori del bisogno del
prodotto a parlare di valori di uscire
dalla propria sfera del bisogno di
entrare in una fiera più personale
quella valoriale e quindi raccontare
quello che rappresentava il valore che
rappresentava quell'azienda e quel
prodotto Ed ecco che nel momento in cui
l'impresa esce dalla formula di eroe e
di Elisir e diventa mentore che aiuta il
pubblico al consumatore ad entrare ad
avvicinarsi al proprio prodotto perché
questo è vicino ai propri valori
vi faccio un esempio semplice
Io da piccola guardavo abbastanza
televisione Poi mi sono messa a fare
marketing non perché guardavo la
televisione Ma perché sostanzialmente mi
piaceva soprattutto la pubblicità e la
pubblicità e la guardavo soprattutto nei
periodi di festa quindi a Natale quando
stava a casa da scuola i miei genitori
che lavoravano entrambi e non sapevano
cosa fare negli anni 90 mi mettevano
davanti alla televisione perfetto E cosa
facevano che pubblicità c'erano a Natale
Beh come tutti sapete cosa si parla di
pandoro panettone cioccolata
cioccolatino
Ecco che mi ricordo ancora molto bene
che c'era un simpatico signore Ambrogio
che
E questa bellissima signora vestita di
giallo che aveva sempre un leggero
languorino
e io tutte le volte che vedevo quella
pubblicità quando andava al supermercato
dicevo Lo voglio anch'io quel
cioccolatino Lo voglio anch'io perché
avevo un leggero languorino e quindi mi
veniva fame
Ma se noi guardassimo oggi lo stesso
prodotto la stessa azienda lo stesso
signor Ferrero oggi non più ma i suoi
eredi come promuovono quel prodotto a
Natale del 2022 Accendi loro che è in te
bellissimo Ma se noi lo sapessimo che
c'è un cioccolatino dietro faremo fatica
a capire che accendi l'oro che in testa
parlando di un cioccolatino Ovviamente
la comunicazione non è solo una
comunicazione scritta ma la
comunicazione fatta anche di immagini Ma
perché capite la differenza tra quello
che era un bisogno a quello che è un
valore l'oro L'oro è un qualcosa di
prezioso qualcosa che
noi abbiamo bisogno di trovare a Natale
perché a Natale è un momento prezioso un
momento che vogliamo condividere con i
nostri cari e quindi proprio in quel
momento dobbiamo condividerlo con
qualcosa di altrettanto prezioso ossia
il cioccolatino del signor Ferrero
Quindi vedete la differenza
Ed è proprio nella differenza e proprio
nel modo in cui le aziende comunicano il
proprio prodotto con il proprio valore
che
che sta la comunicazione di oggi tutti
Oggi noi oggi comunichiamo ma
comunichiamo in maniera veramente facile
intuitiva tutti facciamo parte di
Community tutti leggiamo recensioni cioè
prima di fare qualsiasi cosa Ormai
abbiamo bisogno di capire se in quel
posto ci siamo stati ci siamo andati che
recensioni ha 5 Stelle una stella Ci
arrivano le mail ok da 1 a 10 quanto
valuteresti è un continuo Ok tutti
continuamente comunichiamo e
comunichiamo con l'azienda l'azienda
oggi non è un entità astratta ma è
qualcuno che raccoglie la voce del
proprio consumatore e ne dà valore
perché ad oggi le imprese senza la
vostra voce senza la nostra voce la
nostra storia non sarebbero nulla non
avrebbero alcun valore e quindi è
importante che tutti noi
continuiamo a comunicare a raccontare la
nostra storia che sia bella che sia
brutta Comunque è una storia e comunque
qualcosa che dà valore a quell'impresa
ed ecco questo il gatto il gatto di
Rovigo perché perché c'è stato Sanremo
Sanremo bellissimo spettacolo fino a
pochi anni fa quando si parlava di
Sanremo Si parlava di il presentatore le
canzoni gli ospiti gli ospiti
internazionali i vestiti delle delle
modelle si parlava di tutto questo ma
oggi noi di Sanremo cos'è che ci
ricordiamo di che cosa si continua a
parlare di Sanremo delle Rose di Blanco
del pensati libera e poi di altre cose
che non sono legate alle canzoni ma sono
legate a quello che è stato quel quello
spettacolo quella comunicazione e quindi
L'azienda che è dietro al pensati libera
è stata da mentore ha aiutato
Chiara a comunicare un valore in cui
tutti noi o comunque chi di noi si è
riconosciuto e quindi ha ulteriormente
comunicate quindi non ci sono più grossi
investimenti mega spot tra un una
canzone un'altra ma la comunicazione e
l'azienda diventa mentore diventa aiuta
il proprio pubblico a entrare con il
proprio valore nella vita di ognuno di
noi e a migliorarla e quindi nel pensa
ti libera tutti quanti ci riconosciamo
si riconosce anche il gatto che si pensa
libere dice Dammi le crocchette e la
comunicazione non è più quella della
pubblicità Ma è quella che tutti noi
facciamo perché tutti noi ogni giorno
raccontiamo una storia e tutti noi ogni
giorno raccontiamo una storia rispetto a
quello che compriamo rispetto a quello
che facciamo
E come tutte le storie che ci si
rispetti vorrebbero tutti che finissero
ok E tutti vissero felici e contenti Beh
non è sempre così lo sappiamo a volte ci
lamentiamo a volte lasciamo delle
recensioni negative a volte ci
arrabbiamo del fatto che le aziende non
ci ascoltano ma tante altre volte invece
siamo noi gli influencer e siamo noi
sponsor di Quelle aziende E quindi se
non ci fosse un etti vissero felici e
contenti Vabbè sarebbe comunque soltanto
un'altra storia da